for fitter rolls throwback to the 80s
something that we've all forgotten about
how to make the perfect shoe pastry
first and foremost important turn the
oven on 125 mils of milk 200 ml of water
in to the pan it's important that we
bring it to the boil slowly butter
caster sugar
salt
it stops it from becoming over sweet and
gives a really nice sort of rustic
flavor to it off the heat 150 grams of
plain flour vigorously fold that flour
in back
onto the heat
like that look beautiful just hanging
off the spoon
cool
eggs
it's really important you put the eggs
in one at a time therefore you get this
really nice incorporation of the white
and the yolk look beautiful
piping bag
one nice lump
and look
just coming through there she is there
greaseproof paper stop them from
sticking to the tray down push
and twist away perfect now finger
into a bowl of water and just push down
those little pointy parts
this stops with it all from burning into
the oven 18 to 20 minutes chocolate
sauce we use between sort of 60 and 70
percent pure cherry the better the
chocolate the better the sauce simple as
that
and the secret now is to melt this
chocolate over a pan of simmering water
that will melt within three to four
minutes
butter honey
just look now that's beautiful smooth
and just this wonderful texture there
take it off the heat
and that now is perfect milk
out
creme chantilly basically a really nice
flavored cream
icing sugar
vanilla
and then mix it
nice piping bag
push in
fit a roll generously fill up to see the
cream bouncing back at you and just
stick them together lovely icing sugar
chocolate sauce into a jug
buffet rolls with chocolate sauce and
chantelle cream
done
for dessert it's an incredible but easy
hazelnut meringue tower guaranteed to
wow your mates
start with the basic meringue separate
four egg whites
[Music]
and whisk
[Music]
gradually add caster sugar
until the mix forms stiff glossy peaks
gently fold in ground and chopped
hazelnuts
[Music]
a trick we use in the restaurants is to
use the mix to stick baking sheets down
which makes them easy to spread and
stops the sheets blowing around
[Music]
top meringues with more finely chopped
hazelnuts
and bake for 25 minutes
and the trick to stop them cracking is
to turn the oven off and let them cool
inside
for the filling melt dark chocolate in a
bowl over simmering water
and slightly cool
whip the cream until it forms soft
peaks and gently fold in three quarters
of the melted chocolate until combined
build your towel with alternate layers
of chocolate cream and meringue
[Music]
finally drizzle over the remaining
melted chocolate to decorate
a simple yet luxurious dessert your
friends will love but be warned they'll
all want second helpings
a really nice exciting quick cheesecake
served with a strawberry and blueberry
compote biscuits
blitz
hot pan
sugar
we're gonna form a really nice light
golden caramel butter
as the butter dissolves put in your
biscuits
[Music]
coat the biscuits in the caramel they
become really nice and crunchy
cool
[Music]
very compact hot pan
sugar
strawberries
blueberries
and look what's happening now we've got
that really nice caramel texture
delays the pan with this little baby i
creme the cassis give it a really nice
dark texture
cool
cheesecake cream cheese in
vanilla
icing sugar to sweeten up the cream
cheese
mix
lemon
cream
whisk
i'm going to fold the cream into the
cream cheese
fill
biscuit crumbs
to release the cutter heat round the
outside of the ring blow torch very
gently
compost
[Music]
touch of mint
that has to be the perfect quick
delicious vanilla cheesecake
then in a cheesecake with berry compote
done
[Music]
strawberry glory a great way of
celebrating the best of british
strawberries
strawberries half
icing sugar
ultimate vinegar the combination of the
tartness of the vinegar against the
sweetness of the strawberries is
mind-blowing drizzle over the
strawberries icing sugar
pan nice and hot
strawberries in caramelized literally 15
to 20 seconds a quick toss then back out
creme patisserie commonly known as a
really nice thick custard milk cream
boil
egg yolks
sugar
whip whip
[Applause]
flour
take out one third of the cream of milk
stir once that's liquefied put all of
your milk and your cream in there put it
back in the pan bring the custard up to
the boil which will cause it to get
really nice and thick
[Music]
[Applause]
into the fridge to cool down
cream
icing sugar don't over whip the cream
just as it's starting to fall through
your whisk
get your thick custard
take off one third
whisk
the rest of it straight in
look at that
nice just
falling through the whisk now for the
exciting part putting this little baby
together
strawberries
juice
pastry cream crushed meringue
repeat
really nice bald vanilla ice cream
sit down on top of the thick rich
custard
juice
grated chocolate
it wouldn't be complete
without one of these
a good old-fashioned british wafer
[Music]
strawberry glory
done
and a sticky chocolate fridge cake what
are your favorites a marshmallow and
peanut fridge cake
perfect for
a picnic
first things first you have to slowly
melt the chocolate
that's bad that's good
i'm gonna break up the chocolate
right in there next butter goes in
couple tablespoons of golden syrup
it's so good
if we melt chocolate too quickly it
starts to separate and destroy
the best and safest way to melt
chocolate is always use a bain-marie but
i'm going to keep a really close eye on
mine and heat it over a super low heat
this stunning little cake has your
favorites in there our digestives now
put your hands in there and give them
like that one at a time
and crush what's the one thing that you
love about a picnic
i love eating outside especially on a
nice summery day
not so much in the wind today no
that's going to be the crunchy part of
our fridge cake
and it's called a fridge cake because it
can sit in the fridge or you can freeze
it now the peanuts in please
can you use it without peanuts if you're
allergic to peanuts oh you can do yeah
definitely now
what are these little babies cranberries
cranberries
from there
marshmallows my favorite okay
they're so bright aren't they why do you
love marshmallows so much because
they're so squishy all right give that a
nice mix up
chocolate is melting nicely okay i want
you to pour that in and i'll mix it nice
and gently slowly slowly slowly
nice
now
touch more please
good isn't it good give that little mix
with daddy please look they're all melty
nice and
gooey
now we're going to line the tray
so this is quite easy to make because um
you don't have to bake it
you just set it
yeah i want you to start pushing it into
the corners please with your fingers
just laying out nice and flat
ah it's all nice and marshmallow and
oozy
to get all the spatula okay and look
how delicious does that look
really delicious i can eat it right now
but i couldn't because it's not set
so when that sets okay
it'll go nice and firm and then we can
cut it into little bars little squares
triangles triangles
[Music]
good
but the important part pushing it down
is so we can slice it
and the more we push the thinner we can
slice okay
[Music]
you